- Calls are mounting for the resignation
and potential impeachment
of the South Dakota Attorney
General Jason Ravnsborg,
after he struck and
killed a man with his car.
This is an absolutely bonkers legal case
where last year, Ravnsborg
admitted to striking a man
with his car.
He said he was doing nothing wrong,
and it was just one of
those freak accidents.
But the evidence seems to show
that the victim actually flew
through the man's windshield,
leaving his eyeglasses
inside the interior of the car.
Then Ravnsborg went back the next day
and found that the man had passed away.
Ravnsborg claims that he wasn't drinking
and was paying attention.
But "The Daily Beast" reports
that it seems that based
on the internet traffic
of his phone,
Ravnsborg was actually
reading conspiracy theories
about Joe Biden at the
time that he was driving,
and struck and killed the man.
This is an absolutely
bonkers investigation.
And it's clear why people are
calling for his resignation
or impeachment from the
top law enforcement job.
So we may see him in court just like
we'll see you in court
if you don't subscribe.